he was dad to me so he was I knew he was
special on the outside because of the
rest of the world but for me he he was
my hero and my friend and taught me how
to hunt and fish and play baseball and
do all those things that you teach your
son to do he had six boys right but then
there was the professional side as well
and how do you remember that aspect of
your lives together I always felt that
if dad could be professional
then nobody in the world had the right
not to be so when we would do Christmas
shows and and he would be working it was
all very casual we would sing around the
breakfast table and do the Christmas
carols for the Christmas shows that we
would do every year but by the time we
got to the set we all knew our lines and
we were never late and so he made it fun
he made it fun do you think he realized
the impact that he was having on
audiences at the time I think dad was a
huge star before my time and he
absolutely knew that he was enormous the
thing that was important to him was less
the fame than possibly more what he
could do for others he was very under
the radar and very modest and had a lot
to be modest about but I know that
towards the end of his life when he
would talk about the things that were
important to him the impact that he had
on people it was it was supporting the
troops it was the the war efforts that
he made that were the ones that he felt
really counted he wanted to fight in the
war didn't he but he couldn't he was too
young to fight in World War one and too
old to fight in World War two
so I'm impacted that have on him it just
made him do whatever he could do in
whatever way he could to be there anyway
and he did he raised money for war bonds
he went overseas
and performed for the troops he went to
the hospitals and he did I think the
most touching thing that he did was that
he would write to the parents and the
families of the troops when they were in
hospital beds and couldn't and he would
write to the soldiers and those were
those were letters that he kept tell me
about the letters because you find him
recently relatively recently well we
were my mom was was cleaning out the
attic and there's always a lot of stuff
and memorabilia and and he did save a
lot of things but these were in a box
and they were clearly important to him
and he had saved every one of those
letters from the soldiers and and it was
quite tragic because some of them were
returned to sender because the soldiers
clearly hadn't made it but he kept them
and they were dear to his heart and some
of them were letters from soldiers to
him to tell him how important
he'd been in their lives yes and some of
them were from family members that told
him how much it meant that their brother
or their son could see him perform and
and they all they all carried a punch
and he he he said of all the things that
he done in his life he felt that was the
most important white Christmas did dad
know how important it was as a song at
the time
me
just like the wall
[Music]
so it came out in 41 right after Pearl
Harbor was bombed and and by 42 it had
become you know the anthem for soldiers
overseas and for anybody that wanted to
come home um what do you think
contributes to its longevity do you
think it just reminds people of a family
and gathering around the tree or reminds
people of ones that are no longer there
what does it mean to you
for me it's incredibly yeah for me it's
it's just such sweet memories because it
epitomizes who dad was and and what he
was about and of course I grew up with
it and I grew up with him singing it so
it's it's very close to me in my heart
[Music]
and Mayall
[Music]
d why let me just show you my Christmas
memory of your father with you if I may
my son was eight months old when it was
his first Christmas I know my mother
sadly had just died I remember holding
him in my arms and being at the
Christmas tree and singing white
Christmas to him what it's your favorite
memory of white Christmas and your
father we used to sing it every year on
the Christmas shows and so I remember
white Christmas just growing up through
the years every year we would sing it
there would be a different guest on the
shows but it it was my childhood my
entire childhood I don't have one memory
I have sort of like snapshots of growing
up and singing that song together as a
family and do you still sing it I only
sing in the shower
god forbid I do anything in public that
I'm not even remotely good at knowledge
I can assure you it is it's an absolute
honor to meet you Mary thank you so much
for joining us what a treat to me thank
you thank you